talk about two Facebook nonsense that
Donald Trump is fighting for his legal
life as he faces criminal indictment
over hush money he paid to the porn star
Stormy Daniels or that's the allegation
anyway but that doesn't seem to be the
only thing ruffling the former
president's feathers he wasn't overly
impressed that I sat down with his
current most formidable presidential
rival the wildly successful governor of
Florida Ron DeSantis it's a whole show
that will Air tomorrow night and it'll
make riveting viewing but not even
Donald Trump will make America great
again a group formed of his allies
released a statement earlier saying Ron
DeSantis is lashing out against
President Trump in my interview because
his poll numbers keep falling
unfortunately DeSantis sitting down for
an interview to bash president Trump
with gun Grabber Piers Morgan won't
solve his issues with Republican voters
well to be clear I don't like grabbing
guns I don't actually like guns at all
it didn't stop there shortly later to my
lack of surprise uh president Trump
himself to his social media platform to
say while I'm fighting against radical
left lunatics persecutors and unfair
prosecutors who want to destroy us all
Ronda sanctimonious is not working for
the people of Florida as he should be
he's too busy chatting with the ratings
challenge TV hosts in England
desperately trying to rescue his failing
campaign but it's my fault I put him
there then if he's talking about Rhonda
sanctimonious or me there at the end um
but in view of sitting down with me
president Trump you seem to be suffering
from some Amnesia because you've sat
down with me yourself about 40 times
including three times when you're
president of the United States so it
couldn't have been that bad anyway I
joining me now as a former senior
counselor to president Trump from 2017
to 2020 kellyanne come with Kelly
kellyanne lovely to see you
hi Paris thanks for having me I always
think it's the high point of flattery if
Donald Trump takes time from his busy
day annihilating everybody else to
launch a personal Savage attack on on me
and thoroughly enjoyed it today and it
wasn't unexpected but behind it I'm
curious what you think of what's going
on here in terms of how he views Ron
DeSantis and how damaging if at all this
whole legal thing in New York is going
to beat him because it seems the more
that people talk about it the more his
poll numbers seem to be improving
so first things first on the DeSantis
Trump question I gotta congratulate you
for getting the governor to sit down and
give a major interview and back to back
then you had a former president perhaps
future president
um make Elevate you on social media so
you're having a really good week Pierce
Morgan uh in terms of DeSantis I mean I
think president Trump has made very
clear he feels that Ron DeSantis should
be more grateful to him for giving him
his endorsement in the primaries when
DeSantis was famously at three percent
showing pictures of his infant and
toddler children uh building walls and
having a Maga onesie on and everything
and then of course campaigning for him
and Ronda Sanchez won the first time
with less than 50 percent of the vote
very small margin but what does Santa's
has done in Florida since is pretty
remarkable he's been an excellent
governor on many accounts and uh and I
think Trump has the Santas where he
wants him right now Trump's poll numbers
are going up the Santas is not a
declared candidate and even you sitting
down for an interview about Rhonda such
as governor of Florida
is forcing him to respond to Donald
Trump so I think all of these candidates
are going to be asked the most popular
common question is going to be Trump I
think so far Senator Tim Scott handled
the question the best I watched him an
interview and he was asked the
legitimate question Pierce so how are
you different from Donald Trump on
policy where do you differ that way we
would think that you're also for an
America First agenda and Senator Scott
said we probably differ very little
that's really the right answer well I it
was interesting it's interesting because
I do think yeah just on that point I
mean I did ask DeSantis that question
let's see what he said let's play the
clip
people have been quite kind of scathing
they've said you're house trained Donald
your diet coke to his full Coke right
you've heard all this stuff what are the
differences between you well I know what
I I know him very well I'm having now
spent time with you I could immediately
identify a few differences but what do
you think of the differences well I mean
I think there's a few things I mean
obviously you know the approach to covid
was different I mean you know I would
have fired somebody like fauci uh I
think that he got way too big for his
britches and I think he did a lot of
damage I also think just in terms of my
approach to leadership you know I get
Personnel in the government who have the
agenda of the people and share our
agenda if you bring your own agenda in
you're gone we're just not going to have
that so the way we run the government I
think is no daily drama focus on the big
picture and put points on the board and
I think that that's something that's
very important I thought that was an
interesting response it wasn't
particularly about policy although
obviously covid he would argue that by
being a must uh much more free in the
way he responded to it in Florida it
turned out to be a smart move but on
this question of how he runs government
there's no doubt is it if Trump gets
back into the White House you were there
last time you were probably one of the
lone voices of calm sanity but all
around you was daily drama and Chaos I
mean there was it's indisputable and I'm
sure that would be the same again Donald
Trump thrives off that kind of stuff so
there you have a clear point of
difference in style DeSantis struck me
as somebody pretty serious-minded he's
not a you know he doesn't go out with
all the the lobby gang he's not a
Washington guy he just wants to do his
job and as he puts it rack up the score
and he's been very successful in Florida
I mean he turned to 30 000 majority
first time he ran for governor tiny
majority to 1.5 million uh arguably the
standout Republican star of the the of
the midterms so he's positioning himself
as a different kind of leader albeit
they pursue a lot of similar policies
yes I don't believe that the Republican
nomination is going to be won or lost
appears on gender on age on Race on
style and not substance people are
drowning economically they're searching
for pockets of air many of them do want
the guy back who they felt made them
more prosperous and safer now there are
plenty of other people who want an
alternative to president Trump even
though his poll numbers have been
increasing this year and he's really put
a bit of distance according to the
political morning consult poll just this
week really put a bit of difference
distance between he and Ron DeSantis and
Republican primary electorate but I I
think for DeSantis he should talk more
about policy taxes regulation his uh any
of his National Security and foreign
policy bonifies because I'll tell you
the world feels like it's on fire right
now in so many places yo Xi Jinping and
Vladimir Putin this budding romance who
haven't ran salivating it Israel you
have them also talking to China it seems
like through Saudi Arabia so many hot
spots Ukraine and Putin
um I think these Governors who have a
great story to tell including DeSantis
are going to need to show that they have
what it takes to be commander-in-chief
and National Security
as well let me just make very clear it
won't matter who the Republican nominee
is for president that person will become
unrecognizable
to the rest of us they will do to Ron
DeSantis or anyone else what they did to
Donald Trump and that that's a given I
also was very surprised he didn't just
say damn straight I can when you asked
DeSantis the question can you beat Joe
Biden he said I think so well it's
interesting because when you read that
it sounds like he was in some self-doubt
when you watch it and I'll play the clip
now it comes over slightly differently
watch this
you think you could beat bud I think so
so you're running them no I didn't say
that I just said I think I could I mean
I think that that's I mean if you look
at Florida it would be harder to be
Biden or Donald Trump workout I don't
know those are two different
well they're all two different people
that's for sure but I think it was a
more emphatic I think so than people
have construed it to be I don't think he
was expressing doubt he was like yeah I
think so yeah I could beat him but it
was interesting it's far lesson that's
right it doesn't say in his eyes I think
he just wanted to make it clear that if
he runs he's running to beat Biden to
the White House he doesn't just see this
as running against Donald Trump
that was one of the smartest things he
said recently electorally he should
transport people into the general
election and say I'm going to run
against Joe Biden and there there's a
significant contrast between as many
contrasts between Joe Biden and Ron
DeSantis but he that road runs through
Donald Trump of course the nomination
but that was smart I guess he's less
emphatic and more hesitant than his
donors and his supporters and those who
insist that he can be by let me tell you
some electability is a fiction I cannot
guarantee who can and cannot win years
before voters exercise their choice and
voice the way when the presidency peers
is not through electabilities through
electoral college and you have to go and
win those key States like Pennsylvania
Wisconsin Michigan a whole bunch of them
and you got to start with far to look to
Santa's in Florida Kim Reynolds in Iowa
Mike dewine in Ohio these are three
states peers that Barack Obama carried
twice that are now ruby red DeSantis and
Kim Reynolds re-elected with 19 by 19
Mike dewine reelected by 25 percent of
the vote so the Republican realignment
in some of these states that were
previously purple if not blue as I say
Obama abide and carry them twice has
been truly remarkable okay
how to win Wisconsin Michigan and
Pennsylvania
let me ask you about Donald Trump in
this case the Stormy Daniels Scandal
um two questions really about this one
is do you think he's going to get
indicted and secondly will that help or
hinder actually his chances of winning
back the White House
well piers in true disclosure I
testified twice before that Manhattan
grand jury in this case and I think I
was called there because of the I was a
campaign manager and clearly this was
not a matter of the campaign it never
crossed my desk and it certainly
wouldn't have broken our stride I was
thinking of one woman at the time in the
fall 2016 her name was Hillary Clinton
not the porn person he expects to be
indicted he expects to be arrested and I
I can tell you in having sat in the
grand jury I think many of the grandeurs
themselves were paying wrapped attention
taking notes asking questions but it's a
very unfavorable place for Donald Trump
and that the threshold to indict someone
is far lower than to prosecute them and
convict them what I think long term it
helps president Trump in that
electorally speaking people do circle
around him they say you've picked upon
him so much you're picking on me too I
think he's got other legal matters he
needs to still outrun that have nothing
to do with that that case that this D.A
passed on earlier his predecessor passed
on the FEC in this country said no to it
the department Justin said no it's a
very odd case to bring now it's a very
odd case to bring now to try to get a
misdemeanor books and Records under New
York law to become a felony and indict
the president but there is a whole bunch
of people goes beyond the Trump base in
this country Pierce who are so tired of
just trying to get Donald Trump when
they feel like we need to get the
economy back in order get energy
Independence back get crime lower get
inflation inflationary prices lower get
the border under control people are very
upset about that it's not just the Trump
base which by the way is 74 million
people to begin with yeah it's a there's
a lot of Truth in that and I I'm I think
making him a martyr over something which
is comparatively trivial like this I
think could be a strategic political
error and I think it is politically
motivated so I wouldn't disagree about
that have you spoken to the president
this week
I have yes I have well can you send him
a message just say look it's the first
anniversary of Piers Morgan uncensored
the show that he said was catching dead
flies I think about nearly a year ago he
was my launch guest interview so rather
than ranting about Ron DeSantis sitting
down with this this guy in England what
about we do the reunion the anniversary
interview
uh president Trump reunite go to him
yeah pass the message I like it I will
recommend that to him um I certainly
came I'm his warm-up band I suppose and
I I'm sure if you went to Tallahassee
for the interview you'd be willing to go
to Palm Beach for the interview I'd be
in Palm Beach in a heartbeat so I was
there last time that's why we did it in
miralaga happy to get on a plane many
times and pass in one of my my very best
kellyanne great to talk to you I will do
that sir thank you pierce all the best
all the best